my name is John Taylor and I'm the head
of sports science accessible club we use
science in sport read for two reasons we
trust the stringent testing procedures
in terms of banned substances and the
wide range of products really help us
cover all the major bases that we need
on matchday injury developing a proper
nutrition plan can really give our
players an edge we play so many games
and we have such a short turnaround
between each game we play on average
every three days so making sure that our
nutrition is right and we're getting
players to fuel at the right time really
really give us a huge benefit leading
into the next game the majority of
several matches are won and lost it was
there at the end of the game and we know
that most goals are scored later in the
half particular towards the end of the
game performance intensity and drop over
ninety minutes if players energy levels
drop and they have less fuel and form of
carbohydrates in their muscles to use so
we try and make sure that we keep those
carbohydrate levels topped up so we use
science in sport going into gels they
are small easily digestible good players
quick to tape we happen to the players
at halftime we have someone a touch line
if they want anything during the game
just to make sure they keep going all
those things again
post-game it's all about recovery
getting some protein on board to help
with muscle damage carbohydrates to
refuel them again because they would
have used a lot of what they took pretty
much immediately postgame there's
increased blood flow to those major
muscle groups in the legs and upper body
that been working during the game so we
know that those carbon protons delivered
straight to where they needed